i love sugar free like i told him
at the end of the night when he was like
man thanks for having me you know it's
love appreciate you and i was just
saying to him i'm like man dawg i owe
you man like
taking your style i was able to go get a
deal and provide for myself and my
family that's incredible and
and just also the fact that you're very
like you pay homage to him because a lot
of people
they don't have the humility to do such
a thing right he said he was like man he
was like i [ __ ] with the fact you say it
in front of
you know all your boys i'm like nah they
all know i love you man yeah like you
know everybody know i ain't ashamed of
that
um like i just seen um i was talking to
g perico um
sunday and i was telling him some things
about him that i super [ __ ] with and
any artist that that i'm a real fan of
that i really [ __ ] with like
like my boy would tell you i was in
there with dom and i was saying like dog
i want my hats the way i wear them
because of you
i'm not one of them rappers that's too
cold right right to give up to give up
if you see somebody and you [ __ ] with it
you you let them [ __ ] you let them know
that you [ __ ] with it
me and mikey uh me and mike from mike
and keith we was um talking about
supreme because i'm really into you know
surprise
[ __ ] so we was talking about it was like
man you know the first [ __ ] we
were seeing in that [ __ ] was casey
veggies
facts i'm like yeah i was like bro casey
was one of the uh
the first young fly dudes like yeah
people people don't give
you know casey enough credit when it
comes to like what him and anwar were
doing like
2013 2014 and just that whole movement
when it came to like the fashion
and like right you know so he was
talking about that [ __ ]
and then casey pop up at the spot we was
at so i was telling i was like nah yeah
i remember
you know cause i started quoting these
lyrics to him from this this [ __ ] he had
called the pennies back in the day
so i rather told him he he's he laughing
he's rapping it with me and [ __ ]
and i was like yeah i remember the video
you had them uh the brown and purple
the supreme timberland joint song it was
like damn for sure did
i'm like yeah but like i'm i know i
correct bro like you know what i'm
saying like i know i can rap i know what
i'ma be
i know where i'm going i know where i'm
headed but i don't i don't feel no way
letting the [ __ ] know like i
know i [ __ ] with you
or at this specific time this certain
[ __ ] you did inspire me because i mean
like
that's important man because at the end
of the day like i'm confident in myself
nobody is nobody got to where they are
and whatever field you're doing
and when it comes to art you know what
i'm saying without without having people
who inspire them
right and to act otherwise is crazy
right yeah don't get me wrong we get on
the court you know i mean i'm still
going of course yeah but you got to give
it like
it's like bro like of course like even
like me like you know the first time
i met big boy or you know it's like yo
like you're i grew up like listening to
you you know what i'm saying like
this is like crazy that i know you know
i still gotta do my [ __ ] though
yeah but it's like dude like you're a
[ __ ] legend like
thank you for everything you've done for
our industries yeah like i'm here
because you know like you know what i
mean like
so i always try to do that especially
with like you know certain
radio dudes like who you know you know i
kind of came up doing like an
underground hip-hop specialty show
right but that came from friday night
flavors which was on the power 106 with
mr chalk and those guys
right and uh you know that they kind
and and when i met sway i was like dude
like i used to
buy the swing king tech freestyle cds
and like you guys are like what i wanted
to be
right i wanted to just play underground
rap music but but see
and the part about that is when you give
somebody flowers like that
a lot of times some game that come back
with it for sure like you learn a lot
yeah like sway bro suede was like you
know as a kid man you know i listened to
um the wake-up show every weekend and
you know to
have a relationship with him is crazy
you know what i mean be like damn i know
sway
right and then he gave it up to me bro
brought me and head on his show and was
like we're the gatekeepers of the west
i was like damn this is crazy someone
should pinch me right now but that's
i saw that video and i figured i said
that in the rap
i'm standing next to sugar free like
[ __ ] a dream somebody pinched me
yeah like i had to put that in the verse
because i really you know like damn
nah man that's big because i know you
you know it's evident like how big of an
influence he is on you and then you and
i talked to
you know four or five months ago and you
pulled up on me and i was like yeah man
i know it's a big deal
that was dope you got to capture that
moment hell yeah